une cartographie du quartier du stade de
france avec différents types de données
le principe de cette plateforme digitale
de sécurité développé par thales un
groupe industriel de défense tu prends
dans l'occident type agression quand je
clique dessus j'ai accès à une fenêtre
qui va s'ouvrir up ici j'ai mon incident
avec un environnement qui a été donnée
est une procédure à suivre par type
d'incident 160 d'un accident données ont
fait une type de procédure cette
solution est conçue sur le site de
vélizy elle est destinée aux
collectivités locales et aux sites
sensibles l'idée est d'assurer la
sécurité à partir des données collectées
par des capteurs la plateforme a pour
objectif de fédérer les données qui sont
les données et les sous systèmes qui
sont déjà disposés dans les villes afin
d'apporter un tableau de bord une vision
concrète de ce qui se passe dans la vie
ça peut être une caméra de vidéo
protection
mais ça peut aussi être un détecteur de
bruit cet ensemble là va permettre de
dire il ya un bruit anormal à un moment
donné dans la journée est-ce que c'est
pas un chantier pirate est ce que ce
n'est pas une fête où est-ce que c'est
pas un incident qui s'est produit
plusieurs technologies ont été présentés
en parallèle des tables rondes
organisées dans le cadre de la matinée
bâtir des territoires de confiance des
échanges entre des industriels des élus
locaux et des représentants de l'état
sur la place du numérique dans
l'activité des collectivités locales là
c'était de voir comment
finalement au travers d'outils on
expérimenterait au plus près des
territoires donc en lien avec les maires
les présidents d'exécutifs locaux
pour l'heure on les fait partager à nos
concitoyens pour instiller ce qu'on
recherche c'est finalement du numérique
de confiance et on a besoin pour cette
confiance ne s'installe que ces projets
d'expérimentation soient portés par les
collectivités locales parmi les projets
innovants menés par une collectivité il
ya le commissariat d'agglomération du
futur un outil technologique qui devrait
voir le jour à elancourt en 2024